sa femme marie antoinette elle n'aime
guère rambouillet qu'elle qualifie de
gothic crapaudière le roi décide alors
dans le plus grand secret de faire
édifier dans son domaine de rambouillet
une laiterie rambouillet fin du xviiie
siècle
marie-antoinette vient découvrir le
présent de son époux le roi louis saez
un cadeau pour lui donner envie de venir
à rambouillet la souveraine préférant
rester à versailles
nous ne sommes pas dans une
reconstitution historique parce que une
de nos difficultés notamment c'est que
louis saez ayant acheté sur ses propres
deniers
c'est en fait une propriétaire royal
mais privé sur lequel il ya très peu de
traces d'archivés lorsque louis saez
fait aménager cette laiterie de la reine
il ménage la surprise de la reine en
faisant construire une palissade de
verdure que nous n'avons pas
reconstituée mais nous avons déplacé
cette palissade de verdure au niveau de
la grille de manière à ce que
l'ouverture permettent de découvrir
cette façade du temple
dimanche dernier un après-midi à la cour
était organisée dans ses costumes du
xviiie dégustation de macarons ou encore
intermèdes musicaux
l'après midi était à l'image de l'époque
de quoi attirer un public de passionnés
la période me fascine oui tout à fait
les costumes encore plus et le plaisir
de se retrouver tous ensemble et de
partager ces moments et ou bien nous
venons de loin comme et de toulouse et
donc on aime on avait participé à ce
type d'événement je ne connaissais pas
le lieu donc c'était l'occasion de
découvrir la laiterie la reine qui pour
le plaisir de venir avec des amis de les
revoir et te balader en beaux costumes
une soixantaine de personnes a décidé de
faire le voyage avant de revenir au
21ème siècle